If you picked any or more or all of
the choices that I gave you, you're not completely
off base. Let me just talk through each of
these choices and why it may be a perfectly
valid choice for the scheduler in picking the next
thread to run on the processor. First come first
search says well, you know there is an, an
order of arrival into the processor, there's a fairness issue,
I'm going to pick the one that became runnable at the
earliest, so there is a first come first serve policy, [INAUDIBLE]
in that. The second is, well somebody paid a lot
of money to run the program, and so I'm going to give
it a priority that it statically assigned with every process
or thread. And I'm going to pick the one that has the
highest priority, so that's also a valid choice. The third possibility
is, a thread's priority is not static. It may be born
with a certain priority, but over time, it
might change. Why might it, might the thread's priority
change over time? Well, for one thing, operating systems
typically tend to give priority to jobs or processes,
or threads what do we even want to
call them that tend to be interactive. That tend
to take a short amount of time on the
CPU and then go off and IO or synchronization.
Those kinds of threads are shortest amount of time that
it takes on the processor, the schedule may want to
boost up the priority of the process and give it
a higher priority, even if it was born with a
smaller static priority. And that maybe a reason why it
might choose a higher dynamic priority. That's a third choice.
And the fourth choice is pick the one whose memory
contents in the CPU cache is likely to be the highest.
What that means is the that thread that has
the cache warn for its working set is likely
to do really well when it gets scheduled on
a processor. And so it makes sense to suggest that
this might be a good choice as well. So,
all of these four choices, one can't argue for
and, for and against. But in this particular lecture,
what we're going to think about is particularly look at this
last choice and that is picking the thread whose memory
contents are likely to be in the CPU cache. Picking
that as a choice, why that makes a lot sense
especially in a multiprocessor, where there's going to be several levels
of caches and, and cohesivenesses and so on and so
forth. We'll discuss more about that in the rest of
this lecture, but I wanted to warm you up with
this particular quiz In which we have all these different choices.
And one can, as I said, argue for or against
every one of these choices, and there are valid arguments
both for and against. But, this is the choice that
we're going to focus on for the rest of this lecture.